quatre années se sont écoulées le temps
qu'il a fallu aux parents de mathieu
pour se sentir prêt à quitter l'ombre où
il vivait reclus
en acceptant de partager leur histoire
ils tenteraient sans doute de recoller
les morceaux de la vie d'avant et de
cette famille dont ils avaient rêvé
sophie et dominique sont restés dans la
maison du gard où ils vivaient avec
leurs trois enfants deux filles et un
garçon pas un jour ne passe sans qu'il
ne pense aux crimes de mathieu prendre
en compte ce qu'il fait agnès légiste il
s'est arrêté je crois il est arrivé à
compter dix sept coups de couteau alors
peut-être y en a plus c'est voilà puis à
préparer un gamin de 17 ans et demi
alors jeune corps sur sur un tas de bois
il allume un feu
voyez il reste là il reste là plusieurs
minutes en train de regarder ce corps
brûlés
je pense à air jeu aurait pu être ma
fille c'est comme si c'était nous qui
l'avions fait ce mal on n'arrive pas à
faire la différence à séparer même si
j'ai intellectuellement gh on se dit non
c'est pas toi c'est mémé ça fait rien
c'est toi qui a donné la vie c'est toi
c'est ton sens et c'est hrc c'était
valeurs que tu as transmis c'est c'était
code c'est et